foreign
well I was wrong so time to own it
what is a photo what is a photo that's a
that's a real question that I'm not sure
has a straightforward answer anymore in
this age of smartphone cameras that we
live in case in point the latest
questions with Samsung now this is a bit
of a part two to a video I've already
made called what's happening with the
iPhone's camera but that's about the
broader topic of smartphone cameras and
computational photography and the more
interesting thing which is taking
pictures of people I'll link that below
the like button this one is more of a
side quest of the specific Edge case of
phones with zoom at night zooming all
the way in and taking pictures of the
moon so first I'd like to admit I was
wrong I made a short about a month or so
ago I'm not going to delete it but it's
of me zooming all the way into 100x
space zoom on the Galaxy s23 Ultra and
taking a picture of the Moon that looks
really impressive and I said I guess
it's not doing the AI fakery that Huawei
got caught doing years ago but to be
fair that's not what I should have done
what I should have done is actually
tested it done some a b experiment type
stuff I should have tested it and ran an
experiment like Reddit user I break
photos actually did this past weekend
and well as you can probably tell the
findings were kind of interesting so let
me show you so basically when you point
a camera in the sky and zoom all the way
into the Moon it recognizes the moon as
a subject of the photo and it locks the
electronic stabilization on the target
sets the focus distance to infinity and
fires up a detail Improvement engine to
make the Moon look much clearer than it
would normally be the easiest way to
prove this is exactly how the Reddit
experiment went if you load up a full
resolution picture of the Moon and point
the camera at it it triggers all these
systems and the same set of processes
but then if you pull up a blurred photo
of the Moon with many of these details
obscured and do the exact same thing
Zoom all the way in point the camera at
it what happens is it still runs all the
same improvements and processes because
it recognizes a moon and then it turns
out the camera will spit out a clearer
more detailed photo of the Moon with all
sorts of sharp detail that wasn't even
in the source image it feels weird it
feels fake like the fact that it's
getting a bunch of detail out of the
shot that wasn't in front of your camera
in the first place just feels wrong
to be fair it's not exactly doing what
Huawei was accused of doing Huawei is
accused of doing this Brute Force like
overlay fakery where okay you point
theirs at the Moon it recognizes the
moon and then it just drops an overlay
on top of the Moon to get that detail
out of nowhere because that's what our
brains assumed that was happening Huawei
denies this but to be fair this would
work with moon photography because the
moon as you know is tidally locked and
the same side always faces Earth so the
overlay would always be perfectly
accurate but what's actually happening
with Samsung's is a little more
complicated than that so like I said you
point that camera at the Moon once you
get past 25x Zoom if the sky is clear
enough and the Moon is recognized as the
target the camera app turns the exposure
all the way down to take it from a
glowing white orb to an actually
somewhat detailed object then like I
said it sets the focus to its furthest
distance it locks the electronic
stabilization on the target object and
then it runs a series of noise reduction
and detail enhancement processes that
basically AI sharpen in what you see in
the viewfinder towards what it knows the
Moon is supposed to look like so yes
everyone who has this phone that takes a
picture of the same moon is gonna get
like basically the same looking image at
100x but it you know if it's got some
color to it if the moon is red to you
then it will keep that intact uh if
something flies in front of it
theoretically that should stay intact
and then it matches the phase of the
moon so it'll work on any phase Half
Moon gibbous Crescent whatever that's
fine too now I might be asking Marquez
how do you know all of this well one
because we actually ran these
experiments on pictures of the moon like
the Reddit user did but also too
there is an entire post on a Samsung
Forum there's a Samsung Community forum
and there's a post that details all of
this like how it works what phones it
works on and the step-by-step process
that it goes through when it recognizes
the moon in the sky it's in Korean so
you may have to run it through translate
to read it yourself but yeah it's out
there
so you can disable this feature just by
turning off the scene Optimizer setting
in the camera app whose description
right now on my phone says it makes dark
scenes look brighter food look tastier
and Landscapes look more Vivid they
should also add also makes the Moon look
extra crispy and bright and detailed so
you can Flex on all your iPhone friends
who don't have 100x zoom but to me this
is just one of many types of photos that
our smartphones are already editing for
us I've said it in a previous video the
the stuff that comes out of the
smartphone camera isn't so much reality
as much as it's this computer's
interpretation of what it thinks you'd
like reality to look like so of course
anytime there's a full moon everyone
with an s23 ultra is super tempted to
zoom all the way in and take the same
picture of the Moon because it looks
super impressive and it's visually cool
but also then the headlines are going to
say hey that's kind of fake but these
phones will continue to recognize the
land escape and turn the Grass more
green or recognize a wide angle shot
with the sky in it and turn the sky more
blue It'll recognize a photo of food and
boost the most saturated colors
of course the one with the Moon is the
most visually impressive and easy to pay
attention to but
what is a photo
Moon mode magic makes the media mad but
many more manipulated megapixels have
their Merit
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one peace
[Music]
foreign